So, diet in arm wrestling: what to eat, how much, and general rules that will guide you through it without doing some stupid things that a lot of people like to do.
So, I have two pieces of news for you.
One is good; the second is bad.
The bad one is that arm wrestling is a sport, and if you want to be competitive, you need to measure your calorie intake and macros.
So that's the bad one, because I know that a lot of you don't want to do this kind of thing, but that's really enough.
And the good news is that an arm-wrestling diet is forgiving.
It's really easier than any diet for the sport I can imagine. It's easier, way easier than bodybuilding. It's way easier than strongman. It's easier than running, cycling, or swimming. It's really forgiving, so this is good news. But you need to be a little bit professional, because usually there's a study for that. I don't remember the name right now, but there is a study that, like, even at the professional level, like Worlds or Europeans, I think that was IFA.
I think so.
I don't remember well, but people were, on average, one weight category too high if they wouldn't be... So they were just too fat, right?
That's it.
If you want to know how much you should weigh, I've recorded a video about weight in arm wrestling, what you really can, how much you really should weigh or can weigh, to not lose a competitive advantage.
So let's go to the diet.
The first thing is caloric intake.
Forget about bulking phase, forget about cutting phase.
All the stuff that came from bodybuilding does not apply to arm wrestling, because there is no justification to go for a five-hundred-calorie-plus bulk.
Just to get your tiny forearm or arm muscles bigger. They are just too small. So no matter if strongmen are doing that, you don't have to. You don't have to unless you are juicing like crazy and you are super heavy and you have to eat ten thousand calories because there is no maximum limit for your weight and every five kilos will give you an advantage, but
it applies only to a few people on Earth who are already at this level of size and strength, and it does not apply to ninety-nine percent of arm wrestlers, maybe ninety-nine point nine.
So just stay at calorie zero, and if you need to get bigger, do something called a lean bulk at one hundred, maybe two hundred calories a day.
That's it.
You don't need to do any more.
And if you want to get leaner, you need to lose some weight.
Just be on a slight deficit.
And that's it.
You can obviously use different approaches to cutting.
So you can do mini-cuts.
You can do intermittent cuts.
So, for example, one day you're cutting, one day you're not cutting.
This is what I'm doing, for example, because it allows me to still progress.
But at the same time, at the end of the week or month, I'm in a deficit, and I had at least my zero on my training days, so I could progress. But this is, like, cutting strategies and preparation for competitions. I will discuss that in different videos. Here is the general thing: cut all extremes. It doesn't really matter. Just stay around your zero. Do not change your weight that much, because really
your muscles that are most important for you do not weigh that much to justify any huge weight jumps.
So, stabilization.
So that's the caloric intake.
About macros.
Let's start with protein.
Okay, so I would say go with at least one point two grams of protein per kilogram of your body weight.
And I don't see any reason why you shouldn't go to one point six, which is the highest measured amount that is beneficial for building muscles.
Even though we are not building at least half of our muscles in arm wrestling, and even though the ones we are building are not pure growth, we want them to be stronger.
So even if this amount of protein is possibly overkill,
you don't pay much for it. I mean, there is no downside to it. So I would say this one point six is a really safe amount to go with. If you want, if you want to struggle with one point six, you can go with one point four, one point two, but here I would say we are active, so it would still be better to go a little bit higher, but it's not really necessary. About fat and carbs, as I said,
arm wrestling is a forgiving sport, so you are not preparing for five-hour runs. You are not, you know, fighting for every single gram of your muscle for the competition. You do whatever you like. You like to have extra fat in your diet, you go this way. You like to have extra carbs, you go this way. Your training, because of the way we train, will not suffer depending on whether you're going to eat like a fat dog the day before or a little bit of rice. It won't matter.
It won't matter.
Just eat whatever you like. Be clean.
Don't go below zero point five grams of fat per kilogram of body weight, because it's not safe.
And in my opinion, rather avoid an extra-low-carb diet, lower than one hundred grams, because that could also hit your performance, not a little bit, but maybe a little bit more than a little bit. So just don't go with extremes, okay? So do whatever you like. Don't go with extremes, and that's pretty much it. If we are talking about this, what can you eat? Okay, so it's again very forgiving. I see no reason why you wouldn't go even vegan if you want.
I just made a video about collagen, and if you want to go there, everything is explained: why it works and why being vegan doesn't mean that you won't have collagen synthesis or something like that.
So vegan, vegetarian, or omnivorous, like a classic diet, if for some reason you want to exclude something from your diet, you won't be hurt.
Your arm-wrestling training won't be hurt.
Obviously, I do not advertise some crazy, stupid ideas like fad diets, like this paleo madness, keto diet, or carnivore diet.
I mean, obviously, I'm not talking about bullshit, right?
You generally should stay away from bullshit, right?
So if it's the Dukan diet or, I don't know, fruitarianism, a fruitarian diet, just eating raw, just don't go with bullshit and you're going to be fine, right?
So even if vegan is already kind of dodgy, right?
It's okay.
So you can go that far to an extreme and you are still right. Just don't go further, okay?
So if you decide you're going to eat beef for, like, three months straight, that's not the best idea, but you probably already know that.
So, yeah, so I think this is okay. Maybe I'm going to touch a little bit on supplements, but, yeah, no, no, I already talked about vitamin C, which is the most crucial.
Basically, if you need supplements, your body will tell you that you need them.
That's my case. I take some supplements,
but I do take them because my body actually told me I need to do it.
So I would say, do not stress yourself.
These five grams of collagen might be useful before training if you saw my previous video, but it doesn't have to be, if you have a good protein intake.
So it's up to you.
So that's it.
Bye.